[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat de france 24 la
présidence française de l'union
européenne s'achève ce jeudi numérique
salaire minimum ou encore taxe carbone
en six mois l'elysée estime avoir
atteint presque tous ses objectifs
malgré les élections en france et
l'irruption bien sûr de la guerre en
ukraine fin février et c'est cette
guerre et ses conséquences justement ont
poussé ces derniers mois le repas à
repenser sa souveraineté énergétique
mais aussi militaires l'europe qui s'est
aussi ouvert pendant cette présidence
française pendant ces six mois aux
candidatures ukrainienne et moldaves
alors le bilan de cette présidence
française est il si positif que l'elysée
la firme en quoi la guerre en ukraine a
permis à l'europe de renforcer son unité
mais aussi sa souveraineté quels seront
les défis pour la république tchèque qui
va reprendre le flambeau on va en
débattre avec nos invités ce soir
caroline de camaret chef du service
europe de france24 bonsoir caroline yves
bertoncini consultant en affaires
européennes et président du mouvement
européen
bonsoir merci aussi d'être avec nous en
plateau adrien broche consultant opinion
à l'institut viavoice bonsoir et en
duplex de rome sandro gozi eurodéputés
italiens renaissance le groupe de la
majorité
présidentielle
d'abord j'aimerais qu'on parte si vous
le voulez bien bonsoir j'aimerais qu'on
parle d'abord à bruxelles retrouver jean
jacques guéry notre notre correspondant
jean jacques bonsoir en ce moment
comment va se passer le passage de
flambeau à la république tchèque mais du
fait du principe de la présidence
tournante ce passage de relais c'est
quelque chose d'habituel à au sein des
institutions l'image la plus visible
évidemment c'était celle du président
français emmanuel macron qui d'après
midi a symboliquement passé le relais
auprès du premier ministre tchèque petr
siala c'était en marge du sommet de
l'otan à madrid lui a d'ailleurs
souhaité bon courage mais en coulisse
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui se
prépare depuis un moment progressivement
les conseillers se parlent pour
faciliter la fluidité de la transmission
des dossiers en cours peu à peu les
conseillers de chèques ont été intégrés
aux réunions au briefing les contacts
étaient réguliers dans les groupes de
travail au sein du conseil alors
de manière protocolaire il n'y a rien de
vraiment prévu mais de façon plus
concrète et plus visible il ya eu dans
toutes les formations du conseil
européen ces derniers jours un passage
de témoin avec souvent un petit discours
ou un échange de cadeaux par exemple à
l'issue du dernier conseil des ministres
ou décorer père qui sont les comité des
représentants permanents des états
auprès de l'union européenne et tout est
fait vraiment pour assurer une
transition qui soit la plus fluide
possible en tout cas la france elle
termine sa présidence sur une note
plutôt positif puisque cinq textes clés
du plan climat l'union européenne ont
été approuvés cette semaine oui et ça
marque clairement une avancée ces textes
est donc tout ça est arrivé sous l'égide
de la présidence française et il y avait
des négociations compliquées chaque et a
tenté de défendre ses intérêts dans les
négociations prenait à l'exemple de
l'automobile par exemple à partir de
2035 normalement il n'y aura plus aucune
voiture neuve à essence ou diesel qui
sera vendue au sein de l'union
européenne c'est la fin du moteur
thermique et résultat on va généraliser
les véhicules électriques ce qui
représente un défi pour les
constructeurs et pour l'ensemble de la
filière industrielle automobile
européenne eba là dessus il a fallu
trouver un compromis l'allemagne par
exemple dont on connaît l'importance de
la filière automobile a obtenu une
concession si la technologie d'ici 2035
permet à des moteurs thermiques de ne
pas émettre grâce à des carburants
synthétiques ou des motorisations
hybrides et bien il y aura quand même
pour ces véhicules là une possibilité de
mise sur le marché et ça a permis de ne
pas bloquer l'accord sur le texte ce
compromis là donc sous l'égide de la
france et l'autre avancée vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure ça concerne le
marché du carbone vous savez c'est ce
mécanisme qui jusque là n'était réservé
qu'aux industriels les plus polluants le
principe c'est que pour avoir le droit
de polluer les industriels doivent
d'abord acheter des quotas de droits qui
correspondent au niveau de leurs
émissions comme ces droits sont limitées
les entreprises doivent ensuite se les
échanger entre elles si elles souhaitent
polluer plus que prévieux bien la guider
avec ce qui a été adopté hier c'est
d'étendre ce mécanisme à d'autres
secteurs notamment pour les fournisseurs
de carburant ou de fioul domestique
beaucoup d'états était inquiet en raison
des répercussions sur le pouvoir d'achat
des consommateurs
alors pour éviter qu'elle ne soit trop
lourde les vingt-sept étaient d'accord
pour la création d'un fonds social pour
le climat le problème c'est qu'à peu
près personne n'est d'accord
ce montant et la france a beaucoup agi
en coulisses pour que l'on parvienne à
un compromis et ce sera finalement 59
milliards d'euros qui permettront de
distribuer des aides directes temporaire
aux ménages les plus modestes alors
évidemment il faut encore parvenir à un
autre un accord avec l'autre législateur
qui est le parlement européen mais ça a
marqué une avancée et ça permet à la
présidence française effectivement de
terminer sur une bonne note c'est une
étape supplémentaire pour l'adoption
d'un plan climat qui est très ambitieux
on le rappelle l'idée c'est de réduire
de 55 % les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 au sein d'union merci
beaucoup jean jacques guéry notre
correspondant à bruxelles justement on
va parler du climat pour commencer si
vous le voulez bien sandro gozi tout
d'abord sur la question climatique est
ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un succès
de cette présidence française
absolument c'est un succès c'est un
succès avec des avancées qu'en attendait
depuis longtemps et que la france avait
aussi proposé des pilons temps mais
c'est cette présidence française et
c'est emmanuel macron qu'il réalise je
pense par exemple à la taxe carbone aux
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne n'ont pas dépit l'époque de
la présidence sarkozy
mais c'est avec emmanuel macron avec ses
prisons françaises qui est cette
mesure très utile très juste pour nos
entreprises et pour notre marché
européen des biens et devient réalité
vous avez vous essayé de rappeler les
paquets climat à l'époque elle qui m'a
c'est quand même un paquet qui nous
finalement nous dont les instruments
instrument juridique les ressources
financières avec les fonds dont vous
avez parlé pour véritablement aller vers
la réduction de 55 % des émissions
carbone d'ici à 2030 pour transformer
l'industrie européenne c'est qu'ils
répondent à des priorités écologiques
mais aussi à des priorités des
compétitivités parce que notre avec ses
quais la présence française est réalisé
nous allons ouvrir une nouvelle phase d
construction d'une nouvelle industrie
européenne qui devra être compétitif sur
l'échelle globale donc je crois que dc
point de vue évidemment il y aura des
egos il ya au parlement européen on est
on est très ambitieux sur ce paquet il y
aura duré a sans doute aidé ciation ou
ultérieur mais j'ai quoique et les
résultats sont là et pas très parlant
faveur on va avoir de la présidence
française caroline de camaret les
résultats sont là sur le climat assez
compliqué parce qu'en fait effectivement
les textes qui avait été annoncé en
début de présidence sont en train d'être
adopté un à un simplement je trouve que
indépendamment de ça on est dans un
autre moment sommes maintenant il ya eu
la guerre en ukraine il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes autour des énergies et de
notre dépendance énergétique à la russie
avec des prix qui flambent de l'énergie
et de la nécessité de générer de
l'indépendance énergétique ce qui veut
dire qu'on est tenté aussi avec une
crise alimentaire qui se profile est
bien de dire à bâle objectif 55 % de
réduction de co2 d'ici 2030 est ce bien
raisonnable et ce qu'il faut pas
recommencer à nourrir les européens est
ce qu'il ne faut pas commencer à faire
du productivisme d'un côté et puis d'un
autre côté faut être un petit peu moins
regardants sur les importations parce
qu'on va devoir importer et bien par
exemple du gaz américain et donc on va
on va polluer en important et c'est donc
il ya il ya à la fois des objectifs qui
sont remplis oui mais de l'autre main on
reprend parce que parce qu'il ya un
momentum qui est celui d'une crise qui
se profile avec la guerre en oeuvre
quand même il bertoncini
ça a été dans le bon sens sur le climat
7 ces six derniers mois oui oui
clairement dans le bon sens l'essentiel
des priorités de la présidence française
ont été atteintes a donc c'est un bilan
très bon de ce point de vue là y compris
sur l'énergie et le climat le premier
paquet énergie climat c'était en 2008
c'était déjà la présidence française
mais celle de nicolas sarkozy cette fois
ci il y avait le pacte vert européen un
paquet 14 juillet dernier quand on
appelle fit for fifty five et la france
a su se saisir d'une partie des textes
un pas tous mais et les faire adopter en
conseil maintenant ce qui va rester a
confirmé et sandro gozi sera bien placé
pour le voir puisqu'il siège au
parlement européen c'est à confirmer un
accord entre le conseil et le parlement
européen si on prend l'exemple des
véhicules à moteur thermique le
parlement européen n'a pas voté tout à
fait dans les mêmes termes mais ça je
dirais c'est la routine habituelle est
en tout cas la présidence française a
fait ce qu'elle avait à faire dans le
cadre du conseil pour mettre les états
membres d'accord ce n'était pas facile
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça caroline a
raison de souligner que le pacte vert
c'est le moyen et long terme c'est 2030
2035 et même 2050 que tout ça est
percuté par des urgences a conclu en
berne la vis-à-vis de la russie la
diversification des approvisionnements
tous les risques aussi d'inflation n'est
pas des risques d'ailleurs cdd constat
est là dessus bon je dirais la présence
française a fait ce qu'il a pu mais ce
sont des problèmes qui demeurent et
qu'il faudra traiter
lors des précédents suivante les
tchèques d'abord les suivra ensuite en
tout cas sûre sur le climat la
perception des français
n'est pas exactement la même dans un
sondage viavoice adrien broche sondage
qui a été réalisé notamment pour france
médias monde on voit que seuls 35% des
personnes interrogées font confiance à
l'europe sur cette question climatique
comment l'expliquer on est tout à fait
bien cette perception ouais c'est un
score qui peut paraître un peu rude
comme ça mais il faut savoir quand même
que sur la question climatique
globalement dans l'opinion on perçoit ça
de manière tellement j'ai envie de dire
presque métapolitique la question
climatique c'est à dire c'est difficile
de de l'accroché de parvenir à
véritablement
proposer des solutions concrètes qu'on
pense aujourd'hui crédible sur la
question climatique on pense beaucoup
plus à des choses en fait qu'ils sont de
l'ordre individuels ou de la prise de
conscience au personnel que bon c'est un
score qui nous pour le coup ne nous
surprend pas tellement là où
effectivement je pense que c'est plus
sujets à être à être à faire figure d'
alerte c'est que si on s'intéresse par
exemple à la question de l'innovation
technologique ou de l'économie l'union
européenne apparaît comme beaucoup plus
solide pas dans des scores qui sont non
plus absolument parfait mais en tout cas
autour de 50% de français considèrent
que l'europe est une force aujourd'hui
pour l'économie pour les défis et
l'innovation scientifique donc c'est
vrai qu'on est un petit peu un petit peu
plus bas c'est un score qui doit alerter
la question climatique l arrivée un peu
trop tard au sein de l'union européenne
sûrement trop tard je pense qu'elle est
arrivé trop tard sur le plan de l'union
européenne mais sur le plan politique de
manière générale évidemment il ya une
prise de conscience qui s'accélère
considérablement mais du point de vue de
la résolution et des acteurs légitimes
pour résoudre la question climatique de
manière générale dans l'opinion c'est
assez difficile de la raccrocher à des
acteurs institutionnels ou à des
organismes directement est là parce que
je veux pas vous contredire avec votre
propre sondage mais moi j'ai quand même
j'ai quand même lui de très près aussi
ce sondage donc qui est donc pour france
24 et france télé et
radio france
il fait apparaître qu'il ya une
inquiétude mais presque métaphysique sur
sur l'état de l'économie et que cette
inquiétude elle a grandi de 20 points
c'est à dire que 73 % des français
estiment que finalement la situation
économique va se dégrader je crois qu'on
peut peut-être l'affiché on doit le voir
le sondage trouve que c'est quand même
assez en contradiction avec l'idée que
l'europe a fait plein de choses super
mais pas assez quand même pour que cette
voie là 74 donc on et ses 20 points de
différence avec les ajustements six mois
en début de présidence et cette
dégradation n'est pas dû seulement à la
présidence des mets ma profonde tout à
fait juste quand quand on utilise ces
sondages elle est due aussi au fait
qu'il ya eu un impact un doute l'impact
de la pandémie dont on sortait un petit
peu on était en train de finalement
nouveau respirer et être dans une phase
d'espoir quand on a quand vous avez
testé les français il ya six mois et que
maintenant on est retombé dans quelque
chose qui est on va on va vers la
stagflation la fellation là encore c'est
toutes les conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine de traverse et on en reparlera
après justement il bertoncini la france
avait présenté un programme très
ambitieux alors il y avait le climat
bien sûr on vient d'en parler aussi le
numérique le social en six mois l'elysée
d'y avoir mené à bien entre 95 et 97 %
de son programme est ce que le bilan et
si positif oui mais je crois qu'il est
très positif le bilan mais j'ajoute et
le sondage doit nous inciter à le faire
qu'il s'agit d'un bilan sur des
obligations de résultats législatif mais
ce que regardent nos compatriotes c'est
pas l'adoption d' avancées législatives
sont les résultats concrets je veux dire
dans leur vie quotidienne bien sûr ça
n'enlève rien au fait que ce bilan
législatif est très positif il les a
écrits percuté quand même dans le dre
wimedia moyens à moyen et long terme et
donc ça explique que quand nos
compatriotes regarde ça d'une manière un
tout petit peu moins microcosmique moi
je suis partie du microcosme donc je
salue le bilan très positif mais quand
il regarde en termes d'inflation les
comptes en termes de réchauffement
climatique et continue à faire trop
chaud hein il continuer à voir du
dérèglement climatique
il considère sur le climat que c'est
sans doute trop peu trop tard et sur
l'économie caroline de camaret bien de
le dire on est en pleine stagflation la
situation se dégrade l'inflation ses
sacres sampdoria sur deux et ils ont du
mal nos compatriotes je dirais les
français les européens or microcosme
auront donc du coup plus de mal à
s'enthousiasmer pour un bilan qui est de
fait très positif mais qui n'est qu'un
bilan législatif
sandro gozi bilan très positif il ya
quand même quelques ratés ou pas selon
vous
écoutez moi je vous réponds avec les
mots qui ne sont pas les miennes avec
cette phrase c'était depuis 1989 qu'on
n'avait pas une présidence
c'est mestré elle aussi efficace c'est
pas moi qui la disent et frans
timmermans frans timmermans ce n'est pas
français il est néerlandais il
n'appartient parrino et les socialistes
c'est le premier vice président de la
commission et c'est quelqu'un qui prend
acte du fait que les résultats sont là
et ce sont des résultats
impensable il ya quelques tombes s'il ya
quelque chose ou quelqu'un nous aurait
dit il y aura une taxe carbone aux
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne on aura de nouvelles règles
pour lutter contre la désinformation on
aura de nouvelles règles pour
responsabiliser les gars femmes pour
sanctionner l'illégalité au en ligne
pour assurer que tous en tant que
citoyen en tant que sénateur
consommateurs ne nous serions protéger
quand nous allons en ligne pour faire
nos achats open informé c'est les
paquets numérique c'est la loi sur les
services numériques c'est la seule voie
sur les marchés numériques si
quelqu'un nous avait dit on va arriver à
voir finalement un salaire minimum
commun européen et on va voir des
l'équité sociale dans les pouvoirs
d'achat et de tous les citoyens de
l'union européenne il lui aurait dit
mais c'est du rêve est aujourd'hui c'est
si ces réalités après des quads et si on
veut parler et des mesures concrètes
c'est une présidence qui s est déroulée
avec la guerre qui est revenu en europe
et contre la guerre il ya eu six paquets
des sanctions contre la russie on a
donné des milliards d'euros on aide aux
ukrainiens économique on a et on en à
m qui nous permet on va rire les gens
mais la guerre mais je vous réponds non
non non non je voudrais pas passer qu'il
veut et berthon ceni disait oui mais
c'est législatives les français ne sont
pas ça oui les français quand même pour
en ressentir les messieurs quand on te
presse ou l'ukraine après il y à un
récession économique devant nous mais
elle n'est pas provoquée par la
présidence française elle est provoquée
par un conflit sur lesquels il faudra
d'après moi prendre d'autres mesures
exceptionnelles d'un domaine énergétique
économique pont dont la présence
française on a adopté un programme ripa
voyous qui doit assurer la souveraineté
énergétique européenne à travers une
diversification des provisions
énergétique et de nouvelles
infrastructures ce à ses réponses
concrètes mais d'après moi il faudrait
prendre d'autres mesures exceptionnelles
pour assurer une véritable solidarité
économique énergétique aux ménages des
entreprises européennes suite à la crise
ça sans doute ce sera celle des thèmes
déjà au centre du débat et c'est le
thème d'une sur lesquels nous allons
travailler dans les semaines qui
viennent qui en compta devant nous
caroline de camaret je veux que vous
vouliez réagir parce que oui parce que
en fait est ce que la présidence
française a été exceptionnel en fait on
est naturellement tenté de la comparer à
la présidence allemande qui était
justement en fin de mandat dans gala
merkel et qui cette présidente allemande
confrontée à la pandémie à déclencher ou
a réussi à négocier avec les français
d'ailleurs mais a réussi à négocier à
imposer aussi à la commission un plan de
relance de 700 à 1 50 milliard d'euros
non non non les plans de relance non non
non non non les plans de relance c'est
emmanuel macron et les gones allemands
italiens espagnols qui l'ont imposé un
gala merkel c'est l'initiative française
italienne espagnole d'avril 2010 9 qui a
convaincu le gouvernement allemand qui
laisserait d'initiative et la tequila
qui a convaincu angela merkel a signé
cette déclaration franco-allemande du 19
mai 2019 c'est emmanuel macron qui a
fait bouger anglais merkel c'est
l'italie qui a fait bouger un gars mère
qu'elle est bien sûr finalement et la
bouche et parce qu'elle était dans
l'immobilisme pour des années un gala
merkel donc on va pas comparer la
présence allemande avec la présence
française selon der et lens qui a été
conçu par la france conçu par émana
mâcon et défendu par emmanuel macron
devant emmanuel macron mais simplement
ce qui ce qu'il est et ce plan de
relance est inédit et très très très
très original et c'est quelque chose
qu'on arrive pas à m
c'était original grâce à la france
c'était original grâce à emmanuel macron
et grâce à la france part avec
l'allemagne parce que la proposition que
l'allemagne l'avait fait en avril 2019
c'était une proposition au rabais les
allemands ne voulaient pas de dette
commune européenne les allemands ne
voulaient pas des ressources propres et
c'est nous que nous avons convaincu les
allemands aller dans cette direction son
président c'est évidemment de
reconnaître que ça aussi c'était un
travail sur présidence au monde mais ça
veut rien dire la proposition d
française défendue par l'italie et
l'espagne peuvent pas une proposition
allemand tout cas en tout cas
le bilan des manuels macron à la tête
de l'union européenne et pas juger si
positif que sa part parlé français
adrien broche on va voir tout de suite
vous voyez 39% des français qui ont été
interrogés dans votre sondage pensent
que le bilan est négatif seulement 35%
positif la perception est bien
différente encore une fois on a tout à
fait on a pour le coup vraiment une
opinion française qui est divisé sur
cette question 39% des français
considèrent que son bilan est négatif
exactement le même chiffre considère que
l'action des manuels macron n'a pas été
à la hauteur de ce qu'ils auraient
souhaité donc effectivement une opinion
une opinion assez divisés je pense qu'il
faut quand même rappeler qu'on avait
posé la question sur la première édition
de ce baromètre là au moins de décembre
en 49 % des français seulement savaient
que la france allait présider l'union
européenne donc à une distance naturel
qui doit être je pense rappeler est
encore aujourd'hui puisque on a pas mal
quand on s'intéresse aux réponses que
nous font les français de non réponse
c'est à dire de français qui ne se
positionne pas sur cet enjeu donc il ya
une distance un peu naturel ou
construite peu importe mais des français
vous avez vis-à-vis de ce sujet on a
quand même pour un signal positif un
tiers des français 34 % exactement
aujourd'hui qui considère que la france
sortira renforcé de cette présidence de
l'union européenne encore une fois vu
les les la puissance la force des
mouvements eurosceptiques de manière
générale depuis un certain nombre
d'années maintenant avoir un tiers de la
population française qui considère qu on
en ressortira renforcée c'est c'est
effectivement pas mal et peut-être juste
un dernier chiffre puisqu'on est en plus
sur un sur un média malheureusement mais
56% des français aujourd'hui considèrent
que les médias n'ont pas assez couvert
médiatiquement cette présidence
française de l'union européenne alors là
évidemment c'est sûr on est à la tête
des hausses du cac au labour doit
couvert 6 % du temps d'antenne donc on
est
pratiquement au double de tout tout tout
le paf le service français liberté
il ya eu aussi pendant ses six mois de
présidence française des élections en
france justement élections
présidentielles élections législatives
est ce que ça a eu un impact sur
l'action des manuels macron
écouter ça a eu un impact limité il ya
quand même bien eu à un moment où les
manuels macron est tous ces ministres
ont dû se consacrer à l'élection
présidentielle puis aux élections
législatives mais la france a la chance
d'avoir un appareil administratif et
diplomatiques de toute première qualité
qui n'est pas question d'affaiblir un je
le dis au passage et donc qui a expédié
mieux que ça les affaires courantes
parce que beaucoup de négociations à
bruxelles se tiennent au niveau
diplomatique et les politiques viennent
conclure donc ça n'a pas affecté de ce
point de vue là ce que ça affecte en
revanche je dirais c'est la perception
de l'action des manuels macron parce que
je trouve que ce sondage les français
ont toujours raison il est un peu
injuste mais nul n'est prophète en son
pays et il manuel mac non moins que tout
autre puisque précisément cette
présidence s'est déroulée dans un
contexte électoral et que ce qu'est un
projet aussi d'aimer par une partie eux
qui ne cessent à apa et des ah oui et
ceux qui n'ont que ce qu'ils n'ont pas
donné de majorité
au parlement à majorité claire absolue à
emmanuel macron bas il ne lui concède
rompt pas pour cette raison si qu'il a
fait des choses plutôt positives voire
even rodier et vous repère et donc c'est
vrai que cette concordance et les
malheureuses et que moi j'ai toujours
souhaité et je le souhaite même à la fin
même si c'est une présence très réussi
mais pas du point de vue législatif
institutionnelle du point de vue
politique la perception de la présidence
et bien n'a pas bénéficié et puis
l'image de l'europe en france de cette
concordance des calendriers oui on peut
se demander quand même 6 a pas eu un
impact effectivement le calendrier tout
lé sommet ont été rassemblés entre
janvier et mars et puis il ya eu la
guerre en ukraine et donc on a même
organisé dans la gaude ans en très
grande rapidité finalement un sommet à
versailles sur justement la défense
européenne et quelle stratégie qu'elle
boussole stratégique on va par l'adopter
mais il ya eu quand même vous l'avez dit
ça a été entrecoupée et donc emmanuel ma
comptes s'est pas rendu en ukraine et ça
ça je note quand même que est-ce que
c'est lié au fait qu'il était donc en
campagne présidentielle en campagne
législative et qu'ils n'osaient pas
quitter le pays est ce que c'est lié à
d'autres considérations en attendant
c'est vrai que ça a été quand même assez
mal perçu qu'il y aille finalement en
fin de présidence
accompagné justement de mario draghi et
2 et donc dollars à rolls le chancelier
allemand est ce qu'il attendait d'y
aller avec le chancelier allemand etc
mais la vérité c'est peut-être que ça
l'a empêché aussi de quitter le centre
français et d'aller comme beaucoup de
chefs d'état gouvernement en vidant du
crâne pâtissier rendu après en
l'occurrence la patronne de la
commission européenne qui dans ce
sondage est la grande gagnante de cette
de cet épisode parce que vraiment elle a
augmenté augmenter de façon drastique
dans de notoriété en france qui ont
découvert qu'en qu'elle était sur tous
les fronts à la fois pour le coc vide et
puis pour la guerre en ukraine je crois
que sandro gozi voulez réagir à ce que
vous étiez en train de dire non moi je
trouve sa paradoxale sincèrement je
trouve sa paradoxale qu'est vraiment à
paris on puisse dire cela macron a fait
quelque chose qui a été saluée dans le
monde entier ici à rome et tout le monde
a énormément apprécié l'initiative
emmanuel macron appris avec olaf scholz
avec mario draghi pour montrer qu'elle
est très trois grands pays les trois
grandes économies et les très grands
aussi à puissance militaire disons
celles qui ont en plus des moyens
en europe c'est déplacent ensemble avec
aussi les présidents les présidents
romain qui est les premiers pays
affectés ensemble un message d forte
volonté politique de solidarité et une
visite qui a déterminé un tournant parce
qu'elle ait fait qu'on a donné le statut
de candidat à l'ukraine 2 2 les skis
c'est en tournant fondamental pour
l'europe on a changé la nature de
l'élargissement on a transformé avec
cette visite l'élargissement d'un
instrument géopolitique et maintenant
nous devons transformer aussi la nature
de l'union européenne d'où l'insistance
des monnaies macron aussi pour changer
réformer l'union européenne y compris
réformer les traités c'était un passage
historique et d'entendre et tous les
capitales ont salué de cette façon et
d'entendre à paris on critique mâcon
parce qu'ils étaient il s'est pas
déplacé tout seuls trois semaines avant
moi je trouve que c'est une critique
injuste infondées et que je vous assure
les reste de l'europe et aussi le reste
du monde a énormément apprécié qu'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de comparaison
entre l'impact qui a eu l'image dans le
train des mario delas et you love
chaussée monnaie mâcon qui vont acquis
et finale mana nga cas comparaison avec
les autres initiatives qui ont été pris
à erquy f1 mais pas seulement ces longs
mois selon les observateurs européens et
internationaux yves bertoncini moi je le
dis amicalement à sandro gozi qui
connaît très très bien dans notre pays
le fait que ce déplacement interviennent
pour le coup dans la dernière semaine
avant les législatives ça avec un
discours au pied de l'avion je crois pas
que ça a beaucoup aidés emmanuel macron
à avoir la majorité claire qu'il aurait
souhaité donc là et je maintiens il y
avait une concordance fâcheuse des
calendriers même si en revanche je
souffre je soutiens et j'approuve ce que
dit sandro sur la réception
internationale j'ajoute est donc
positive de ce voyage à 4,1 rappelons
qu'il y avait aussi le roumain qui
étaient là et c'est très important le
président roumain maintenant sûr je
trouve la guerre en ukraine en
exactement sur le même registre que le
registre législatif précédent énormément
de choses ont été faites par les
européens c vrai on peut le souligner
sauf que sauf que ça n'arrête pas la
guerre c'est le regarde les choses sur
le terrain sauf qu'à l'heure où on parle
il ya des ukrainiens qui se font
massacrer et donc c'est bon même s'il
résiste vaillamment et donc c'est bien
qu'on puisse souligner qu'il ya eu des
avancées y compris dans la gestion de
crise la gestion de la guerre les
européens se sont soudés ça à faire il
s'agit des raisons sanctionné oui mais
moi j'appelle à le faire de manière
positive sans triomphalisme excessif au
regard des résultats concrets sur le
terrain parce que nous n'avons pas
arrêté vladimir poutine hélas et
j'ajoute ça va faire bondir cendres
gozzi que l'attitude française vis-à-vis
de la russie avant le déclenchement du
conflit la tentative café emmanuel
macron vis-à-vis des deux l'a dit mais
routine d'abord on n'était pas très bien
perçue ailleurs en europe celle là en
europe de la lépi hélas hélas hélas je
dis bien hélas hélas échoué et ensuite
qu'il ait pu dire qu'il ne fallait pas
humilier la russie c'était une erreur
alors chacun fait des erreurs mais en
tout cas c'était très très bien qu'ils
puissent aller en effet en ukraine avec
des homologues européens pour la livre
le deviner ce qu'il a dit lui même
tourné la page mais s'il fallait tourner
la page c'est bien qu'il y avait une
page à tourner j'aimerais qu'on écoute
maintenant emmanuel macron il s'exprimer
tout à l'heure depuis le sommet de
l'otan à madrid sommet qui s'est achevé
après trois jours
dans ce contexte justement bien sûr de
guerre en ukraine on en a parlé
l'europe souhaite renforcer sa capacité
à se défendre on écoute tout de suite
emmanuel macron
la guerre décidée par le président
poutine en ukraine est une faute
stratégique majeur y compris pour
lui-même il a réussi à ce que des états
qui jusqu'àlors était resté dans une
posture
parfois plus prudente ou plus en réserve
à l'égard de l'alliance décide de même
de la rejoindre
le résultat très claire
du choix délibéré unilatérale la russie
de lancer une guerre aura été le
renforcement de l'alliance
et le renforcement entre européens au
sein de cette alliance voilà renforcer
l'europe de la défense renforcer la
défense européenne avec une dans une
coopération aussi avec l'otan adrien
broche dans le sondage que vous avez
réalisé cette gare en ukraine elle doit
réaliser elle doit inciter l'union
européenne à se doter d'une armée pour
sa propre défense pour 73% des français
donc les français ils soutiennent cette
idée qu emmanuel macron
soutien lui-même depuis longtemps de
défense européenne de souveraineté
européenne
d'un point de vue militaire tout à fait
de toute manière dès qu'on a l'occasion
de reposer la question est de l'amener
de l'armée européenne c'est l'occasion
est là plus que jamais je dirais qu'il
ya un double enjeu de protection qui se
dégage de cette guerre en ukraine dans
l'opinion il ya effectivement ce premier
enjeu là l'enjeu de la défense
d'ailleurs de la défense au sens de la
défense européenne où 73% des français
considèrent que en terme d'incitation la
guerre doit apporter justement et
influencer le projet politique européen
de ce point de vue là mais aussi en
termes de renforcement des budgets
nationaux des états membres sur les
questions de défense dont il ya vraiment
ce premier ce premier registre là qui
est assez marquée et peut-être sur un
autre mais on a un petit peu évoqué tout
à l'heure alors que on est dans un
contexte où 74% des français considèrent
que l'économie européenne va se dégrader
on a un deuxième rejet dépenser plus
pour voit la mairie terre alors
effectivement mais on a un deuxième
registre de protection qui est plutôt un
registre de protection économique et
financière qui pour 63% des français je
crois doit à nouveau être un objet un
objet est un objet d'actions de
protection l'union européenne vient
ensuite la question de la souveraineté
énergétique donc deux niveaux vraiment
de deux d'incitation d' influence que
doit que doit avoir la guerre en ukraine
de ce point de vue là l'armée la défense
la sécurité au sens presque physique de
protection des frontières et des
populations mais aussi dans un contexte
d'inflation de crise et c'est un soutien
une protection économique financière et
à un renforcement de la souveraineté
européenne et ils sont d'ailleurs 61 % à
penser que emmanuel macron a eu raison
de continuer à dialoguer avec vladimir
poutine si on avait pu penser que ça
allait avaient porté préjudice justement
dans les élections et que si certains
pays de l'est justement le critique
parce que vous avez parlé de ne pas
humilier poutine mais même des pays
comme la pologne et la hongrie le créer
aux critiques un dialogue avec un fait -
la hongrie davantage la pologne et les
pays baltes critique un dialogue même
avec vladimir poutine les français lui
donne raison là dessus parce que
effectivement on essaye coûte que coûte
deux soeurs tir sortir de cette phase de
guerre simplement ce qui a de vraies moi
ce qui me frappe sur la défense
européenne souhaitée par les français
c'est qu'on en est quand même très très
loin c'est à dire que en vérité certes
on va renforcer des capacités les
capacités aussi mélina l'aéroport avait
déjà été renforcé avec l'otan voilà
aujourd'hui les les budgets défense 2 %
pour l'allemagne 2 % du pib et c sont en
train évidemment d'augmenter de
d'augmenter considérablement à hauteur
de ce qui a été promis d'ailleurs à
l'otan et entre aux européens mais en
vrai l'armée européenne
on n'y est pas du tout et donc certes
l'histoire a donné plutôt raison à
emmanuel macron qui a mis ce thème sur
le tapis très très tôt un effectivement
dans sa précédente campagne les prises
de earth des autres mais pour autant on
n'y va pas à marche forcée c'est à dire
que on va à des capacités
supplémentaires dans le cadre de l'otan
yves bertoncini est-ce que aussi j'ai
une autre question avant que vous
répondiez est-ce que aussi l'europe a eu
la chance en quelque sorte d'avoir la
france en la présidence française quand
cette guerre en ukraine a été
a débuté la france qui a pu donner son
expérience diplomatique
justement est peut-être permettre aussi
cette unité européenne a assez inédite
non absolument en 2008 d'ailleurs
c'était déjà pareil elle présidence
sarkozy la russie a envahi la géorgie
bon cette fois ci la russie envahi
l'ukraine
c'était déterminant que la france essaie
tout son mérite et je veux leur dire
d'avoir pu à la fois poussé un agenda
législatif ambitieux largement réalisée
d'un côté et contribuer à une gestion la
gestion d'une guerre une crise imprévue
avec gelée rappeler quelques petites
fautes de carre quelques petites erreurs
mais enfin globalement la france à
contribuer et aussi charles michel
président du conseil européen madame van
der leyen qui a été très active carwin
le cam harel a redit les autres
capitales nationales mais donc on peut
le mettre au crédit de la france est en
effet si ça avait été un autre pays je
dirais peut-être moins dotées plus petit
on aurait eu beaucoup plus de
difficultés on le verra d'ailleurs pour
la présidence tchèque président tchèque
va boire et manger sur la guerre en
ukraine et l or à moins peut-être de
chantier légiste va être un défi de
maintenir cette unité européenne sur le
long terme alors la question de l'unité
européenne je vais dire sur les
questions de défense c'est réglé 1 le
temps je crois n'a jamais été en état de
mort cérébrale mais maintenant elle est
en état d' alerte opérationnelle la
défense militaire de l'europe face à
moscou c'est l'otan voilà d'ailleurs
l'adhésion bienvenue de la suède et de
la finlande montre bien qu'à de plus en
plus de pays de l'union européenne qui
sont autant il reste plus que quatre qui
n'y seront pas et donc ça s'est réglé
mais en revanche il faut que les
européens jouent leur rôle dans ce cadre
là le fait que par exemple danemark et
vous leur revenir dans la coopération
européenne en matière de défense ça
c'est très positif ça montre que la
défense militaire de l'europe face à la
russie ce n'est pas tout il faut aussi
se défendre à la de la russie d' sur la
cyber des cyberattaques dans l'espace
etc les européens ont une carte à jouer
et puis y'a pas que la russie il ya
d'autres menaces le terrorisme et c'est
donc les européens doivent
impérativement ils ont commencé à le
faire et la présidence française a
permis des avancées par exemple acheter
des munitions ensemble lancé des
programmes d'armement ensemble il ya un
fonds européen de défense qui existe
déjà donc là il ya des achats communs
qui se profile
thierry breton a joué un rôle d'ailleurs
c'est aussi un commissaire européen
français il faut le souligner est très
positif dans ce contexte là mais plus
largement je dirais que la france doit
bien doit bien se positionner doit bien
montrer que bien sûr qu'elle est pour
qu'on renforce et c'est ce que dit ce
sondage la défense européenne mais je
crois que c'est surtout dans notre pays
que le fait que la défense européenne
soit assurée largement par le temps que
c'est un problème politique jacques
j'observe qui a d'ailleurs les deux
forces qui ont fait une grande poussée à
l'assemblée nationale la france a
soumises elles le rassemblement national
sont pas très otaniens si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire sont pas très il
s'enrichit sur même proche de poutine ce
qui est assez intéressant aussi c'est
que donc il faudra sortir de cette
compte l'europe elle protège en tant que
tel à ce nous plions pas qu'il ya
l'autre mouvement dont parlait
d'ailleurs sandro gozi qui a été initiée
sous présidence française c'est la
moldavie est évidemment l'ukraine en
guerre qui donc se voir reconnaître un
statut de candidat de façon très très
express soyons honnête très très express
leur album high yield et jacky par
rapport au chemin habituel un statut qui
n'ouvre pas encore les négociations et
qui évidemment un long chemin encore
mais il y a quand même une clause de
défense donc mutuelle car donc l'article
42 7 dans les traités européens qui qui
sont relativement protecteur et une fois
qu'on est rentré seulement c'est à dire
dans quelques années et qui qui sont
intéressantes aussi parce qu'on se rend
compte que c'est cette europe aussi
protectrice et démocratique que l'on
veut rejoindre et qui est beaucoup plus
désirable et ça c'est quand même aussi
une des leçons de cette guerre en
ukraine et peut-être que les français
ont contribué avec les autres européens
à rendre cette europe beaucoup plus
ouverte et où on n'impose pas finalement
sa loi par les armes désirable sandro
gozi et les plus désirables l'europe
aujourd'hui
absolument oui absolument oui parce
qu'elle est europe a montré finalement
la capacité de réagir elle a réagi comme
vous l'avez rappelé pendant la pandémie
avec ses programmes exceptionnels
150 milliards et la réagi aussi pendant
la guerre en ukraine évidemment on
aurait vu lui vaut lui tout le monde
aurait voulu pouvoir arrêter arrêtez les
conflits mais l'a démontré d'avoir une
capacité
d lire elle a démontré d'avoir sens de
l'histoire c'est ça la différence et ça
c'est grâce à des leaders comme mario
draghi manuel macron passé sont des
leaders qui ont eu les sens de
l'histoire et des
déplacés à kiev des poser la question d
europe géopolitique des poser la
question dès la réfonte de l'union
européenne comme ils ont fait les deux
et devant devant nous par la montée
européen à deux reprises ça veut dire
avoir le sens de l'histoire l'europe
était rentré dans une nouvelle phase
historique et dans d'autres beaumont
elle manqué des leaders qui étaient
capables d'interpréter cela aujourd'hui
la différence qu'on a faits d'incidents
c'est moi c'est exactement celle ci
après bien sûr moi et j'utilise une
expression chère à aÿ berton ceni moi
j'étais à la recherche des pères
fondateurs et des fils réfondateurs 1 je
pensais pas que parmi ses fils
réfondateurs j'aurai retrouvé vladimir
poutine blessés ça qui s'est passé à ce
que l'agression inouïe des vladimir
poutine contre nous contre nos valeurs
contre nos libertés contre l'ukraine
disons de façon violente physique
militaire mais contre nous tous à donna
à donner finalement raison devant tout
le monde y compris les baltes y compris
des polonais y compris les hongrois où
ils étaient ces pays car macron 2010 est
posée la question de l'europe souveraine
et de l'europe puissance militaire du
sel et quelles étaient leurs réactions
en 2017 qui dit quelle a été la réaction
de la réaction des angles à merkel
carmack rond dans les discours de la
sorbonne a posé les thèmes de l'hérault
puissance de la cybersécurité de la
transformation européenne vous voyez
tous ces éléments là aujourd'hui sont
une réalité
aujourd'hui sont ces d'autres dont on
débat et c'est ça aussi avoir un
leadership et c'est d'avoir un vision et
j'ai foi on peut dire que le
groupe on aurait dû aller à halle on
peut dire que l'europe a grandi faire
sauter de grandir maintenant
écoutez je suis je suis né sur un sorin
une petite rivière qui s'appelle les
roues beacon non mais que vous
connaissez bien parce qu'il ya césar qui
a franchi le rubicon ne rentrons de la
gaule l'europe qu'on a commencé à
franchir le rubicon avec les mesures
qu'on a pris l édition qu'on a pris sur
l'élargissement à l'ukraine sur les
aides militaires à l'ukraine on a
commencé les planchers franchir
maintenant on est au milieu de la
rivière pour arriver de l'autre côté il
faut entamer sérieusement à un processus
des réformes internes l'union européenne
s'était replacé ses voeux puissance
géopolitique doit être aussi efficace
merci on laisse messier urban pouvoir
bloquer avec 1 0 les cinq sont contre la
russie on n'aura pas cette union
européenne efficace que nous voulons
merci sandro gozi un tout dernier mot
très rapidement caroline de camaret sur
la république tchèque qui va prendre la
présidence de l'union européenne son
principal défi ça va être l'aide à
l'ukraine justement alors sont peu c'est
pas le défi c'est d'abord que c'est bon
et dirigée par un conservateur peut être
falla fiala qui est quand même un homme
relativement posée mais qui quand même a
appartenu cette république tchèque au
fameux groupe devise grade qui jusqu'à
présent joué les trublions avec les
hongrois les polonais et les slovaques
de l'union européenne notamment quand il
s'agissait des questions migratoires et
aussi du bon respect des injonctions de
bruxelles sur l'état de droit et qui
aujourd'hui se retrouvent dans le rôle
du sauveur où exactement de celui qui
est inscrit à l'agenda comment sauver
l'ukraine en plusieurs sommets et donc
c'est un rôle assez inconfortable c'est
ça reste un pays de taille moyenne
d'europe centrale et on verra s'ils s'en
sortent tellement mieux que les français
et on suivra ça de très près merci
beaucoup merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
été présent pour ce débat rester avec
nous sur france24 l'information
continuation